Québec autorise le retour des chambres
multiples en CHSLD c'est une directive
qui va dans le sens contraire des
recommandations dans le même la
littérature scientifique et les
recommandations de la coronaire j'ai un
camel qui s'était penchée sur les décès
en chscd au début de cette crise de
covid elle est en faveur des chambres
individuelles nous allons en parler avec
le docteur Annick Duprat qui gériatre
l'hôpital Pierre Le Gardeur bonjour
alors vous travaillez dans ce secteur là
vous voyez certains de nos aînés qui
vivent dans ces résidences là quand vous
avez entendu ou quand vous apprenez le
qu'on dit oui allez-y 3 ou 4 par
résidence quand c'est possible vous avez
réagi comment
mais j'aimerais ça présenter une
perspective différente du problème
actuellement le milieu de soins aigus
c'est un milieu encore moins sécuritaire
pour les personnes âgées en attente
d'hébergement d'abord au niveau de la
prévention des infections là c'est pas
mal compétitif c'est pas mieux à
l'hôpital et ils ont aussi des chambres
multiples actuellement mais en plus
c'est pas un milieu de vie qui est
adapté c'est un environnement qui est
agité il y a pas vraiment d'activités
ils ont rien à faire donc il y a
beaucoup ont des problèmes cognitifs on
est pris avec des troubles de
comportement comme de l'anxiété de la
désorganisation et le personnel est pas
formé pour gérer ça parce que sont
formés pour faire de la médecine aiguë
donc l'hôpital c'est vraiment un peu un
bon environnement il faut garder aussi
en perspective que quand une personne en
hébergement occupe un lit à l'hôpital
c'est une personne âgée malade qui est à
l'urgence qu'on ne monte pas et à
l'urgence c'est un environnement encore
moins bon et ça augmente le taux
application puis de mortalité qui
entraîne des pertes d'autonomie
irréversibles donc on choisit un peu le
moindre mal ici le même si c'est pas
idéal puisqu'on sait que ça va
surcharger le personnel du CHSLD mais
l'hôpital c'est un environnement encore
moins sécuritaire pour ces personnes
âgées là donc je pense que c'est une
décision qui est dommage mais on faut
avec les ressources qu'on a il faut être
capable d'offrir des soins sécuritaires
pour les personnes âgées qui sont à
l'urgence aussi je vais aller dans le
même sens que vous dans ce que là si
vous nous dites un point de vue modéré
c'est tout à fait
dans dans les choix qui s'offrent à nous
si on va en CHSLD il va falloir que ça
change même si on les met à deux à trois
ou à quatre par un par chambre là
qu'est-ce qui va falloir qui change dans
les chscd ça va falloir mettre ça en
application tout de suite
mais je pense que le défi ça va être la
charge au niveau du personnel c'est
certain que c'est un environnement plus
calme et plus contrôlé donc ça va
permettre une meilleure mise en place
des plans d'intervention pour les
personnes qui ont des troubles de
comportement qu'on va utiliser moins de
médicaments pour compenser donc je pense
que ce que le gouvernement va devoir
faire c'est d'augmenter certaines
ressources pour pas que tout repose sur
les préposés les infirmières on parle
des techniciennes en éducation
spécialisée en particulier des gens qui
font de l'azo thérapie de la
musicothérapie tout est des professions
qui sont accessibles disponibles ça peut
être aussi les clones thérapeutiques
pour occuper ces personnes
âgées là pour permettre une intégration
plus facile puis aussi pas se ramasser
avec justement plus de personnes âgées
qui ont rien à faire mais je vous répète
qu'à l'hôpital ils ont aucune dignité il
rarement ils sont habillés en plus de ça
parce que c'est beaucoup plus compliqué
de gérer ça donc
que c'est pas une décision facile mais
moi je vous dirais honnêtement là si
j'avais un parent qui est en attente
d'hébergement là je préférais qu'il soit
pas à l'hôpital est-ce qu'on a les
ressources au moment où on se parle
est-ce qu'on a les ressources pour les
autres thérapies de tous ces de toutes
ces de toutes ces fonctions essentielles
dans les CHSD ce qu'on a la main
d'oeuvre pour le faire ce travail-là
dans les CHSLD dans le moment
je vous dirais que jusqu'à présent dans
ces secteurs-là des professionnels
d'activité là je pense pas qu'il y a une
pénurie on a beaucoup d'artistes qui
peuvent contribuer des musiciens des
gens dans le milieu du théâtre les gens
ensothérapie je crois je crois que c'est
plus une question d'investissement ça
fait longtemps qu'on en parle et qu'on
demande d'avoir ces ressources là et
c'est donner avec parcimonie je dis pas
qu'il y en a pas mais c'est trop peu
fréquent dans la vie quotidienne du
patient par rapport à ce qu'il aurait
besoin pour l'occuper puis une vie plus
durait agréable et en fait une vie plus
digne un docteur Duprat c'est bien bon
de vous entendre d'avoir un autre un
autre son de cloche dans ce dossier là
alors merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec
nous ce matin à la prochaine
bonne journée pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]